We got in the previous video when
Toussaint Louvreur had been Khin,
On some levels, first by his close associates,
Because they joined Lekelk's side
Or basically because they gave up the rebellion against Lyclerc,
They were convinced that Leclerc was not so bad,
He had no intention of returning slavery
Or taking civil rights
Of free men of African descent
This is another picture of your chalk here
This is for Leclerc
So he had to hand over his weapons.
Lefwad has gone to Leclerc
He imprisoned him for your clerical,
Put it on a boat,
He sent him to France
He died the following year in 1803.
If he is betrayed
He died in captivity in 1803
It has been on many levels
Of the most important leaders
Not only in Haitian history, but in general
When I take power as I said before,
He did not avenge the white population
And contributed to the support of the Haitian economy
To return and grow
Indeed, he has contributed to the defense of what is now called Haiti
But it was already St. Domingue, against the British Royal Navy.
I forgot to mention that in the ...
Defended against the British Navy
Which was at that time
By far the world's dominant marine
This is what earned him reputation
As a great general
On top of being a great leader
In terms of revenge,
In terms of tactics cut and burned,
In terms of not only the invasion of his enemies,
So Khin,
And to make it clearer
Leclerc deserves the horns of Satan
Although we will meet someone else
Worth the horns of a larger demon
Or that he was in fact a loyal subordinate
For someone who deserves the Devil's horns
In May 1802
Napoleon signed a law providing for
Re-slavery where it did not disappear
Slavery did not go
So it was a bit vague
There were some areas
Which did not disappear by slavery
These include the French colonies in Martonique,
In St. Lucia, in Tobago
But in Haiti things were
- or St. Domingue at that time -
Things were vague
Has slavery really disappeared?
Or has it not disappeared yet?
As it seems, the slaves were free in Haiti
So it was not clear what it meant to Haiti?
But at the same time
The Haitians did not think that would have happened
This was in May 1802
To make things clearer
Napoleon sent a secret memo to Leclerc
Provides for the return of slavery
When the time is right
Return slavery in time
These two people were not a festival
Know the case
They knew they needed help
From some of the former generals of Tusan Louverture
The former close men
In order to keep control of Haiti
But the intention all the time was
When their hands are supreme
To tighten the screws, to restore slavery
And taking civil rights of free men
These men were not fools either
You can remember Desaline
This was a picture of him
He was also a former slave
One of Tusan Louverture's close friends
An influential general
As you remember
Near the end of the fight against Leclerc
He surrendered against Leclerc
And to some extent you can say
Toussaint Louverture raised
But he and some others
Of the former Loftcher followers
They saw the writing on the wall
They did not object to the secret memo.
They received a statement from Martonique, Tobago and St. Lucia
They were told that slavery had been restored
French in this period
They were not people you might want to deal with or trust
When it comes to slavery.
So Dessalin and his comrades carried the weapons again
Dessalin had someone else different
About Tusan Louverture
The only similarity between them
That they were influential military men.
The big difference between them is that
DiSaline was not going down
He was not afraid
To face eye to eye
Here we have a desalsin responsible for what was ..
I think you can call it the rebel slave army.
On the other hand
Leclerc has 40,000 troops
Which appeared with Napoleon
But Desaline was lucky
Yellow fever that spread .. not lucky
I mean people died because of it
But this is the heart of the war
For the benefit of people of African descent on the island
Yellow fever hit the island and killed Leclerc
And killed some 20,000 people
Or that the number you read was 24,000
Of the actual number of French soldiers
Another 8,000 were taken to hospital
So there are 32,000 out of service
Thus, only 8,000 soldiers remained
Suddenly, the course of the war was completely reversed
Change the number in terms of
The type of forces that the rebel army must fight
But they were not all good at what I think at this point because Leclerc
Which I mentioned and gave him two little demon horns
He had been replaced by a person
Worth two large demon horns, named Rochambo
So as not to confuse him with his father
Which has the same name
Who was a hero of the American Revolution
Which fought for France alongside the Americans
But his son ..
As I can tell
He seems like a decent man
But his son was actually evil
There are few people in history
Who you can say about them are clearly evil
He is one of them
He was somewhat desperate,
Yellow fever has infected his forces
He will go to fight hostile enemies
He did things, he was buried.
Let me write these things because they are evil
The Africans are buried
Or rather I should say African Americans
Former slaves are buried, or people of African descent
Bury them alive in the pits of insects
It also boils people alive in molasses
I have read that he is having a party
Inviting prominent people of different races
And be in place
At midnight he announces it
All men will be killed
So this man has a cruelty
His limits were harsh
On men who can catch them
Especially people of African descent
The only positive aspect of his cruelty
For the first time he united
African populations on the island
So he united the former slaves and slaves
And the unity of different races
That was in 1803
I had already said it
We are still at war with Britain
And Britain as I mentioned before
Owns the most dominant maritime in the world
Freely dominant
This man, despite his wickedness and cruelty
He needed reinforcements from Napoleon
If he wants to face the Disalline
Let me be clear on this point
Disalline as I mentioned
He was not hesitant to face an eye.
In one incident
Rochambo buried 500 rebel prisoners alive,
Desaline has hanged 500 French prisoners
It was not a person I thought
To avoid bloodshed
This is something different from Tusan Louverture.
Is a bit of a lesson
If you are fighting an enemy,
If you get rid of the most important leaders of enemies
You will end up becoming a leader
More like yourself and your cruelty
If you betray them reasonably
But anyway enough of my comment.
If the stage is prepared.
War with Britain
Britain controls the sea, especially the Caribbean
This man needs reinforcements to meet
A strong leader of the former slaves of the rebels
But Napoleon is known to reduce his losses
He did it with his troops in Egypt
Is actually someone who does not care
I think, about the individual
But more concerned about himself and his strength
So Napoleon left them hanging
Napoleon saw the writings on the wall
He did not have the ability to penetrate the British fleet
At the same time
Napoleon is fighting that number of wars in Europe
As you remember, the French Revolution
Which precipitated the occurrence of the bankruptcy of France
Napoleon abandoned this man
And they deserve what they deserve
Napoleon abandoned his control of all his colonies
Or any presence in the hemisphere
That was to raise funds
He also sold Louisiana to the Americans
When I say Louisiana, I do not mean
Only Louisiana is currently
Which were so large
There where she was born
Talking about the bulk
Which now accounts for one-third of the United States
Sold all this
He was clearly desperate
He sold it for $ 15 million
This is equivalent to 60 million franca
I have been told that this amount is equivalent to today
About $ 10 billion
So this is ..
If someone said 10 billion dollars
You can own one-third of the United States
You will say it is a very good character.
Currently 10 billion dollars
15 million dollars in 1803, 10 billion dollars today
And yet it was not much, and Napoleon was desperate
He realized that he could no longer maintain
Something too far away
When Britain took over the seas
He was busy with his problems in Europe
So it was a good deal for Americans
Frankly, if not sold to the Americans
It is possible for the British or even the Americans
To take it from him
The result of Napoleon's preoccupation
Disraelin had the ability to destroy Rochambo
And the Declaration of Independence of Saint-Domingues
On January 1, 1804
Desaline declared independence ..
The new State called Haiti
The indigenous name of the island
It means the land of mountains
There is a final note
Because you may be aware or not,
Haiti is a very, very poor country
In addition, after the dislain there happened many ..
- I will make a video about it -
Guided tours of the heads of dictators one by one
People have passed through many wise men
But I want to make it clear
They had started a terrible food.
Although disalline
Independence was declared in 1804
The French did not recognize Haiti until 1825.
Recognition of the French
The only reason not to recognize ..
And you can wait, well who cares about recognition
Who cares about the thinking of the former colonialist?
But that they got recognition
The French have blocked the Haitian trade
They did not allow any trade
To move forward with Haiti
So it was on the front of the gun.
And so they get recognition
Haiti must pay 90 million francs to France
And to clarify the amount of this money
This is a small island or half island
Which freed its slaves recently
They were forced to condemn France
As they were forced before
The United States and Great Britain
So you can realize
Even former enemies agree
When it comes to persecuting a poor island
So they had a religion for France
Which is equivalent to 1.5 times
What the United States paid to buy Louisiana
This was 60 million franca
They got all of Louisiana
France now tells Haiti that they owe it 90 million francs
Which is roughly equivalent
14 or 15 billion dollars today
This was on the population
Who reached almost half a million freed slaves
So it is a terrible amount of debt
To be clear, this is not something.
This was not the craziest colonization of the early nineteenth century
Forced to do this ..
This debt was not repaid with interest until 1947
They continued to pay the debt
To make matters worse
The reason for the debt as they said was the loss of property
This is what France said about why
Haiti's debt to France, is the loss of property
It is mentioned in the list of lost property
Land and slaves.
Since the slave obtained his freedom
It owes France a large amount of money
Since France lost the right to own it
This was only to make matters worse
In fact I was shocked
When I first learned this number
They continued to pay the debt
In a small poor country located here ..
They must continue to pay the debt
To a developed Western state until 1947
For their freedom.